so
just days from the cop 26 un climate
summit in glasgow we meet the event's
president and lok sharma in downing
street
there's a long shopping list of problems
that need to be sorted out
china needs to commit to more there
needs to be an agreement on phasing out
coal it looks like cop 26 is in real
trouble
look you're absolutely right i mean this
is going to be difficult this is going
to be a big big challenge this is
getting almost 200 countries to reach
consensus on some of these difficult
issues that have been outstanding for
six years now it is in the balance
adding to the strain the un has just
issued a dire warning that the world is
way off track in limiting temperature
rises to a safe threshold
the united nations secretary general
said that the issue was a leadership gap
is it a problem with your leadership
my job as cop 26 president is
effectively to act as shepherd in chief
but ultimately this does come down to
world leaders delivering on their
commitments uh you know i i can't force
any one country to do anything
that definitely applies to china it has
already committed to peak emissions by
2030 and net zero by 2060 but global
targets will be missed if the world's
largest polluter isn't more ambitious
we are still waiting for china to come
forward with its 2030 mission reduction
target i had a meeting yesterday with
the chinese delegation and what did they
tell you are they going to move and i
made the same ask again
and i repeated that they along with
every g20 nation has promised before cop
26 four days from now to come forward
with that commitment are you confident
that they will come forward with
enhanced targets i very much hope they
along with every other g20 country that
has not yet come forward will do so it
is china that matters though above all
do you accept that uh well absolutely
china china is the biggest emitter china
matters uh but you know
so they are the biggest emitter by that
by that very statement so if they don't
move cop is in jeopardy
just about all the g20 17 out of the 20
have said that they're going to um go to
net zero by the middle of the century
that is a move but of course that's
that's not enough what keeps me up at
night is uh just yeah thinking about the
complexity of this what we want is for
us to win for the world to collectively
win so that we can say to you know our
generation but also the future
generations that we delivered when it
mattered
that's the ambition
geopolitics may get in the way
in a few days time we'll find out
hannah thomas peter sky news in downing
street